there is an interesting company that is
just starting a new way of branding your
death that's right the urban death
project let's take a look at their
website real quick uh and now I'm gonna
give you some information so that's the
landing page on their website now as you
can see right there's is because death
is momentous miraculous and mysterious
because the cycles of nature help us
grieve and heal because our bodies are
full of life-giving potential we propose
a new option for laying our loved ones
to rest and now I'm gonna tell you a
little bit the idea is centered on the
core a three-story concrete structure
upon which the deceased replace you can
see it right there the body is laid upon
a mixture of sawdust and wood chips
which are crucial to the composting
process as the body settles to the
bottom of the core over the next month
visitors may pay their respects along
the sides of the structure which is warm
to the touch as a result of what's
happening inside I mean that is
fascinating i love that at the end of
this process friends family members of
the community are given a nutrient-rich
compost that the recently deceased has
now become to spread amongst their
gardens and homes beginning the cycle of
life anew i ab so lutely all of it i
feel love love love and I knew we've
been doing a lot NSA stuff and we're
doing Isis and a lot of depressing Ebola
stuff this is pretty cool right it's
this good way to respond to unnatural
things everywhere is kind of what the
way it used to work yeah the dirts
supposed to be made up of everything
that was ever dead yeah and you know not
just broken glass our death rituals over
the centuries have become more and more
in line with our behavior as a culture
which is we take stuff out of the the
natural world we consume it and then we
don't give it back yeah because we think
that we are very important I think this
is a genuinely great idea I love the
idea of composting I have one question
are we required to wait until after
death
that is a good question i'm sure there's
a thank you on the other way all right
how cool is that idea that that because
of the process the natural process
that's happening that it's warm to the
touch I mean isn't this the stuff we
don't we don't talk about death in the
right way probably for the reasons that
you're that you just mentioned but right
we don't spend enough time actually
talking about the the full circle and
the nature the circle of life right yes
well I'm very selfish and I'm wealthy
and I'm going to have myself launched in
a rocket into orbit and then from orbit
I'm gonna have myself dressed as a
circus clown but in a business suit
version of a business clown with an
attache and I'm going to be ejected
towards Alpha Centauri just to mess with
their image of our history and i'll have
a disc of info about humans that's
completely wrong hahaha the universe i'm
coming to mess with you hahaha because
I'm rich and I can do it and then you
land on another planet and then and
identities on your back to live that's
what the movie starts o our our
instinctive survival instinct has been
warped into an irrational fear of death
with intellect and the inability to see
past that moment in time came this vast
mystery and we don't like mysteries
mysteries freak us out you got to solve
them in an hour what answers for
everything that's right and and and you
got it's got to be closed you need
closure every you gotta have closure at
it and the age of miracles where
everything's answered that's right
uh-huh and also up we we gave ourselves
these these lies you know there's an
afterlife you come back as a as a gerbil
you there's all these things that we can
come up with but in fact we die and i
love the idea that there is somebody
who's going hey you know what what if we
just kind of accept that we die and
that's part of a process yeah that
that's that's a it's it's a
consciousness changing idea and i like
it in any way well i'm glad that we're
all on board this i had a feeling you
guys were gonna be on where these what's
a cost
is a good question we have cost we don't
know cost yet it's not so it's it hasn't
been developed yet so it's an idea it
costs nothing it cuz it all support this
free idea the crowd source option
Kickstarter and IndieGoGo or something
like that a final look at starter hey
there's an idea a final thought on this
what would you want once they have your
compost once your family has your
compost what's your friends have your
compost what do you want them to grow
out of you I would like it to be
preserved in formaldehyde and buried in
a steel case you see what he did there
he did food food I'd like to be in a
vertical farm yeah and a new
permaculture vertical farm where they're
suggesting taking abandoned buildings
that are still structurally sound and
putting in greenhouses all through it to
grow different layers of kinds of food
in the building and feed the entire area
organic with filtered air so you can't
get any GMO pollen through the filters
yeah permaculture yeah I mean you're not
making that up that is the future of our
foods we're gonna have to do it yeah
when the outside isn't the friendliest
place to do it yeah for me I will I'd
like everyone to grow mint because I
make a hell of a mojito and I want all
my brand new I want everyone to think of
my desk when they're drinking mojitos